- GOOD MORNING.
CLIVE "DOUBLE DOWN" RUGGINS,
I'M DANIEL TATE.
I AM YOUR PAROLE OFFICER,
AND I JUST WANT TO HELP YOU.
- HOW THE HELL YOU SUPPOSED
TO HELP ME, MAN?
WHAT THE FUCK YOU
KNOW ABOUT THE STREETS,
WHAT WITH YOUR DIPLOMAS
ON THE WALL?
- SETTLE DOWN.
I KNOW THAT YOU MIGHT NOT
BE ABLE TO RELATE TO ME,
BUT I THINK I KNOW SOMEBODY
WHO YOU CAN RELATE TO.
LITTLE HOMIE.
- WHAT UP?
WHAT UP?
IT'S MY FAVORITE CLIVE.
[laughs] WHAT UP, DUDE?
- NAH, DOG, LISTEN.
HEY, MAN, I AIN'T TRYING
TO TALK TO NO PUPPET, MAN.
- IT'S NOT A PUPPET.
IT'S LITTLE HOMIE,
AND I WOULD LIKE
FOR YOU TO TALK TO HIM, CLIVE.
SEE, I USED TO WORK IN
THE JUVENILE CORRECTION SYSTEMS,
AND I FOUND
THIS METHOD VERY EFFECTIVE.
- I AIN'T NO JUVENILE,
MAN, OKAY?
- HE'S RIGHT.
DOES HE LOOK LIKE A KID
TO YOU?
COME ON!
HE'S A GROWN-ASS MAN.
- SEE? WHAT?
- LOOK, IT'S VERY IMPORTANT
FOR YOUR PAROLE
THAT YOU TALK TO LITTLE HOMIE.
- WHAT'S UP, LITTLE HOMIE?
- [laughs]
THAT'S BETTER, MY NEGRUMPS.
HEH, WHAT YOU GETTING
INTO THESE DAYS, MAN?
WHAT IT IS? WHAT IT IS?
YOU GOT A JOB YET?
- [sighs] I'M TRYING, MAN,
BUT NO ONE WILL HIRE ME.
- YEAH, HEY,
FUCK ALL THAT NOISE, MAN.
BETWEEN YOU AND ME, MAN,
AIN'T NOBODY TRYING
TO HIRE A NIGGA WITH A RECORD.
BUT HEY, MAN,
WHAT YOU NEED TO BE DOING
IS GET BACK INTO SOME CRIMES,
MANG.
- [stammers]
WHAT'S GOING ON, MAN?
- ARE YOU TALKING TO ME?
- YEAH.
- WELL, YOU SHOULD BE TALKING
TO LITTLE HOMIE RIGHT NOW.
- WHAT IS GOING ON?
- YEAH, BITCH!
TALK TO ME!
LOOK AT ME
WHEN I'M TALKING TO YOU!
- OKAY, OKAY, FINE.
- [panting]
DAMN!
SO, YOU SMOKING WEED, NIGGA?
- NO, MAN.
NO, NO, LITTLE HOMIE.
I'M DONE WITH DRUGS.
- [laughs]
SHIT.
I GOT SOMETHING.
UH-OH, UH-OH, UH-OH.
LOOK AT THIS HERE, NEGRUMPS.
SMOKE THIS WEED!
- NO, NO, NO, NO, NO, NO, MAN.
I'M DONE, MAN.
YOU HEAR ME?
I'M DONE WITH DRUGS.
I AIN'T DOING ALL THAT.
- I DON'T KNOW.
LITTLE HOMIE
SEEMS PRETTY SERIOUS ABOUT THAT.
- HERE.
- WHAT?
LOOK, I'M CONFUSED, MAN.
WHAT DO YOU WANT ME TO DO HERE?
- WELL,
I WANT YOU TO CLEAN UP YOUR ACT,
BUT YOU'RE NOT TALKING
TO ME RIGHT NOW.
YOU'RE TALKING TO LITTLE HOMIE.
- NOW SMOKE THAT SHIT
OR I'LL SMOKE THIS BITCH
RIGHT HERE.
- OH, MY GOD.
HE'S NOT MESSING AROUND.
I THINK YOU BETTER
DO WHAT HE SAYS.
- OKAY, ALL RIGHT.
LITTLE HOMIE, MAN.
JUST RELAX, MAN.
RELAX, LITTLE HOMIE.
TAKE IT EASY. I'M JUST--
I'M GONNA SMOKE IT DOWN.
WAIT, WAIT,
NO, NO, NO, NO, NO, NO,
NO, YOU CAN'T FOOL ME.
YOU'RE TRYING TO TRICK ME, MAN.
NO, I'M DONE WITH THE WEED.
[gunshot]
OH!
- [chuckles]
CATCH, NIGGA.
[laughs]
DUMBASS!
NOW YOUR FINGERPRINTS
IS ON THE WEAPON!
YOU IN THIS WITH ME NOW, RIGHT?
- OKAY, LITTLE HOMIE, YEAH.
- HMM.
- OH! OH!
- YOU FAILED THE TEST.
I HAVE NO CHOICE
BUT TO REVOKE YOUR PAROLE.
- WHAT?
OH, MAN.
AIN'T THIS ABOUT A BITCH?
- ON YOUR FEET, BABY BOY.
- GET HIM OUT OF HERE.
- COME ON.
- I CAN'T BELIEVE THAT NEGRUMPS
ACTUALLY THOUGHT I KILLED YOU.
- I KNOW, RIGHT?